Alright. Now that you know what we mean about objects, fields, and
records, you can get back to the Festival app with Samantha and Andy.
>> Alright, cool. So we've made some progress, right? We added some fields,
I guess, what should we do next?
>> So let's go back to the Cloudstock record that we
already created, and then add values to the fields we just created.
>> I don't know if that makes sense. Cloud
stock. Okay cool, so right, that's awesome. So the
fields are there, they're not, they're empty I guess,
that makes sense. Do I just hit edit I guess?
>> Yep.
>> Alright, so let's give it a start date. How about November 29th?
>> Sounds good.
>> Okay. an end date. Let's do like, December 1st. It's going to be a weekend
festival. Let's say it can have 10,000
people, and we haven't sold any tickets yet.
>> Cool.
>> All
right, cool. Now we've got our festival object. It's got
all these fields. I think of it in terms spreadsheets.
I'm not a sales force guru like you are. so
how, what should we do in that sort of thinking?
>> So if we're going to think about it like a
spreadsheet, let's take a look on the a tablet. We have
our name, and so that's Cloud Stock, and we have
our start date and our end date, can hold 10,000 people.
And we haven't sold any tickets yet. Womp, womp. Really
we have all of our fields here along the top.
>> Okay.
>> And this is our record that we created just now. But where does
attendees fall into this? Do we create
another column for that? What do you think?